la situation inquiétante au venezuela
notamment pour l'activité pré
pétrolières qui est lourdement touchée à
les plateformes sont complètement
paralysée faute de pouvoir écouler le
pétrole brut
principale source de ce problème les
sanctions américaines et l'effondrement
du secteur
aucune plateforme d'extraction n'était
en activité au mois de juin une
situation dramatique alors que le pays
traverse une importante crise économique
et pour philippe chalmin économiste et
spécialiste des matières premières
l'embargo américain fixie totalement
l'économie du venezuela et coûtait que
l'embargo américain contribue à la
totale paralysie de l'économie
pétrolière vénézuélienne
celle-ci était déjà terriblement touchée
par toutes l'anarchie politiques liées
au gouvernement mme à dos juste un
chiffre dans les années 60 lorsque le
pen a été créé il y avait trois grands
producteurs mondiaux de pétrole qui ont
été les membres fondateurs de l'opep
s'étaient l'iran l'arabie saoudite et le
venezuela et chacun produisent et aux
alentours de 4 millions de barils par
jour au mois de juin
le venezuela a probablement produit
moins de 400 mille barils jour et ce
pétrole comme vous l'avez dit du fait
des sanctions américaines à l'encontre
du gouvernement maduro ce pétrole il ne
parvient pas à l'exporter dans la mesure
où il ya très peu de compagnies
pétrolières il ya très peu de compagnies
maritimes qui veulent prendre le risque
de travailler avec du pétrole
vénézuélien